[Music]
verily I say unto you the era of the
sword and mask is now the time of the
white kill and the white white is not
the time of madness and the time of
contempt
[Music]
come on girl I don't know
he came for me
well then
think of what they deserved
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Witcher Netflix video
about series power and what the special
prophecy that she was talking about in
that scene means it's called it leans
prophecy you may have heard people talk
about it before but if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the Witcher videos I'll be doing
bonus videos while we wait for season 2
to get here because a lot of you might
be finding the show for the first time
also do giveaways for the actual games
or the books so all you have to do to
enter that is just be a subscriber and
leave your biggest theory about season 2
on the video careful for spoilers for
everything from The Witcher Netflix
season 1 as we go through this I'll do
this top 10 style I think I can do this
in under 15 minutes it's complicated but
I think there's a simple way to explain
the prophecy starting with number 10 so
during that scene on the show series
attacked by a group of four former
subjects that she used to play games
with in the street dressed up like a
commoner so regular people wouldn't
recognize her as royalty she kicks and
screams that they used to be friends and
in keeping with the themes of the show
sometimes humans are the real monsters
not the typical monsters you would
expect Geralt to be hired to fight they
don't let up if they make like they're
gonna kill her and steal her meager
possessions in her horse which she
herself had just stolen a little while
ago and in this moment of extreme
distress series elder blood powers kick
in instinctively and she starts speaking
the words of ethylenes prophecy if alene
was this legendary elven healer a long
time ago that first spoke of this
prophecy that ciri is speaking during
this scene the reason why Ceres able to
speak this prophecy without ever having
heard it before herself in her life or
understanding what it means is because
of the elder blood and the power she
possesses ciri is the unwitting product
of a centuries-long plant enacted by the
elves to create a being that was capable
of stopping it Lane's prophecy from
coming true so number nine the elder
blood you may have heard that term and
not totally understood what it means if
you haven't played the games or you
haven't read the books a long time ago
after hearing ethylenes prophecy the
elves started a special program to
create a being that was so powerful in
magic that they'd be able to stop the
prophecy so it became this genealogical
program tracking the gene as it was
passed down from father to son mother to
daughter through generations but what
happened is is that one of the elves
eventually made it with a
human in that passed the gene to the
humans and that's how Siri with the
special power some people think it's a
curse some people think it's a blessing
that gives the users people like Siri
control over time and space giving them
the ability to travel between worlds in
the multiverse so I bet you didn't
expect to find a lot of science fiction
inside this Witcher fantasy story but
that sort of gets into the idea of the
conjunction of the spheres you may have
heard that term during the TV show I'll
explain that in a second - that gets
into the more sci-fi concepts in the
more multiversal level parts of this
story there is a multiverse within the
world of The Witcher it explains where a
lot of the really crazy stuff comes from
that you see during the course of the
show so number eight series prophecy on
the show as she speaks it in this scene
she speaks a shorter version of the
prophecy from the books but it's the
exact same ethylenes prophecy from the
books
the full version goes like this verily I
say unto you the error of the sword in
the axe is nigh the era of the wolf's
Blizzard the time of the white Chill and
the white light is nigh the time of
madness in the time of contempt the time
of end the world will die amidst frost
and be reborn with the new Sun it will
be reborn of Elder blood of the seed
that has been sown a seed which will not
sprout but burst into flame the Sichel
be watch for the signs
what signs shall be I say unto you first
the earth will flow with the blood of
elves there's a whole bunch of stuff to
unpack in that but number 7 the time of
madness what they're talking about here
is the conjunction of the spheres
mentioned by fringe Allah in the
brotherhood of sorcerers it speaks of a
time when they will again be another
Cataclysm on a multiversal scale when
the spheres the worlds from different
realities within the multiverse come
into alignment so if you haven't read
The Witcher books thousands of years ago
before the events on the show and in the
books there was a conjunction of the
spheres and different planets from the
multiverse crossed over with each other
causing all kinds of crazy monsters to
get trapped on this main world of the
show it's also when the elves say
primordial humans first came to this
world from another reality
elves was the original inhabitants of
the world they kind of get into that in
the first couple of episodes of the TV
show humans actually came from another
world and it's also as they say during
this cutscene from the games when
magic came to the world since then
humans have been misusing it for their
own personal gain obviously elves are
trying to save the world save their own
culture that's why they started the
elder blood program so number six when
ciri is chanting about the time of the
sword in the axe being nice she's just
talking about the chaos that's going to
erupt the big war during the next
conjunction or called the next Cataclysm
when the next conjunction of the spheres
happens and the world's align again in
the world as we know at the world were
on right here becomes overrun with a
thousandfold more monsters so while ciri
is still the main part of this she's
meant to stop this Cataclysm from
happening Geralt is also a big part of
this to the time of the sword and the
axe being died because he is literally
trained to fight the monsters that will
be crossing over into our reality the
Wild Hunt is another good example that
like Geralt is capable of fighting the
wild hunt even though they're super
powerful but they're also beings that
come from outside of this world so
number 5 next part of the prophecy when
she talks about the wolf's blizzard in
the time of the white chill and the
white light that's the part of ethylenes
prophecy that speaks about the coming of
the next Ice Age which according to the
prophecy will come in the next 3,000
years covering the earth in endless
winter may call the Game of Thrones
white Walker long night jokes that you
want there's something about these huge
epic fantasy sagas and cyclical climate
change parallels The Witcher book series
started a little bit earlier in the 90s
than A Song of Ice and Fire it's just a
coincidence that they both have climate
change parallels because the stories are
about completely different things number
four there's a special vision that Siri
gets of The Shining tree in the desert
when she drinks the waters of bracha LAN
from Shia kyon the oldest tree in brah :
where all the special water flows from
some of you've already probably figured
out what this means the vision is meant
to be a metaphor for how everything
that's going on in the story is
connected past present future the
multiverse Siri her elder blood powers
Geralt yennefer and premier nilfgaard
the tree represents uracil the world
tree which connects all the different
worlds of the multiverse and the
characters the desert the sand represent
the sands of time in the cyclical nature
of these cataclysms the conjunction of
the spheres even though you thought this
was going to be a fantasy story about a
Witcher hunting monsters there's a lot
of science fiction going on in this to
number three the time of
as its described inside the prophecy is
also the title of the second novel it's
the fourth book technically that would
be the story that they adapt for season
3 of the TV show that's a metaphor for
the coming war in the fact that Geralt
is not going to be able to afford to
have contempt for the world itself the
way that yennefer showed a lot of
contempt for the world in the TV show
like during the Battle of sodden Hill
she didn't really care that much about
the world but by the end of the fight
she finally decides to participate and
take an active role in helping the world
so she unleashes her full power there's
a line of dialogue from the book time of
contempt at the very beginning where
Geralt stalking to this lawyer and he
says what drives you if you want to save
ciri I wouldn't have thought you could
afford the luxury of contempt no that
was badly expressed you can't afford the
luxury of spurning contempt a time of
contempt is approaching which are my
friend a time of great and utter
contempt you have to adapt what I'm
proposing is a simple solution someone
will die so someone else can live
someone you love will survive a girl you
don't know and whom you've never seen
will die so it's just another reference
to the coming war in the conjunction of
the spheres the big Cataclysm that's
coming number two what do all the
symbols in the title sequence mean
because usually there's only one symbol
for each of the titles but in the finale
you have all these different symbols
forming into the white wolf with the
star in the swallow so the solar eclipse
represents the Black Sun under which Ren
free was born the prophecy of the Black
Sun but all these crazy people will be
born that'll lead to the end of the
world the Obsidian star surrounded by
eels represents yennefer the symbol of
her pendant and the other initiates the
conduits of arethusa remember there were
all those eels that were swimming around
in the fountain creating that magical
power
the clawed footprint with the Tamarian
Lily represents the Striga princess a de
the Geralt saved during the season the
Broken Sword surrounded by the tree
represents the tree from series dreams a
YAG gürsel the world tree in the sword
of destiny remember that's the title of
the second book in the metaphor that she
and gerelds destinies are bound together
because she's so important Geralt has to
protect her the female and the male
figures entwined represent geralt and
yennefer and the symbols that she
painted on her abdomen the symbol of her
uterus the dragon represents the dragon
that he's saved during the season and
it's progeny fun fact - because the
games are a sequel to the events of the
books that Dragon eventually hatches and
shows up as a character during the video
games
the shattered lion represents the fall
of sintra than the three final symbols
that formed together here represent
Geralt ciri
in yennefer symbols it's gwyn blade the
white wolf cereal represents swallow
that's also the name of the sword that
Geralt eventually gets for ciri later
when she's an adult and the Obsidian
star represents yennefer the fact that
they come together is a metaphor for how
Geralt yennefer and series destinies are
now bound together so number one what
does this all mean for the season two
plot because season two is going to be
based on the book blood of elves the
first main novel in The Witcher series
but technically its third book overall
season 1 was mostly based in the first
two books which are really just
collections of short stories meant to be
prequels explaining who the characters
are and how they came together before
they actually do come together in blood
of elves the title blood of elves
obviously as you probably guessed is a
reference to series elder blood but it's
also a metaphor about what humans have
done to eradicate most of the elves in
the world in how ciri is supposed to be
the Promised One created to save them
all from this coming Cataclysm they'll
probably get into how she deals with
that knowledge when she starts to learn
how special she is because Siri does
know that she has power but she doesn't
understand what it means where it comes
from and what Geralt is going to do once
he learns who it is that's coming after
Sirian trying to use her power for their
own personal gain so really when you
think about it Siri is actually the most
important character in The Witcher story
even though most people come to this
thinking that Geralt is the main
character just because you typically
play as his character during the video
games and for a lot of people that's
really their only into this actual story
even though the books have gotten way
more popular since the games have
started to blow up so hopefully you do
have the opportunity to check the books
out at some point if you haven't read
them they're fantastic
season 2 probably won't premiere till
around summer 2021 maybe later hopefully
it won't be that late during the year
but I will do update videos about
production when they start actually
shooting the season I'm sure there's a
thousand more questions that you guys
have write them all below in the
comments and if they're any big Easter
eggs that you spotted in the prophecy
that I didn't mention in the video just
write them below in the comments while
you wait for everything click here for
all my Witcher Netflix
so videos and click here for my new
Mandalorian season 2 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see
you